...much slower and more sluggish, and also less demanding to fly.
And depending on how demanding it is, you can also choose the wing loading.
But mostly, of course,
the recommendation is that between this and that take-off weight, that's the size — and from that the
wing loading follows. Usually you don't calculate it yourself.
But if you can — if you're somewhere between two sizes,
and you're not sure what to take — then with the bigger wing
you'll fly a bit slower, and with the smaller wing a bit sportier,
which is more at home with a higher skill level.
Wing loading is always the total take-off weight
divided by the projected wing area.
With the total take-off weight, be careful — it's not the payload.
That's not the same thing.
Payload is actually everything except the wing —
so everything else that hangs off the paraglider.
For wing loading, though, we also count the wing itself.
So the wing — even though, when you double it, it flies on its own —
also counts toward the wing loading in kilos per square metre.
The easiest way is, if you actually
step on a scale with your backpack, the whole flight gear,
with the sandwich, the drink, the hiking boots —
everything that ends up in the air-package on the scale,
and then you have your total take-off weight.
Now to glide ratio — always an interesting topic,
and there's always some discussion about it at launch.
Yeah, what glide ratio does this wing have?
It's always tricky.
The manufacturers don't lean too far out of the window with their numbers,
because in the end it comes down much more to
how you fly and how well you extract the potential of the wing.
Because mostly, within the same wing class, the wings
are so similar — they only differ in a very small range —
that for glide ratio it's much more important
how the handling is and how comfortable you feel on the wing,
than having a wing that gives you half a glide-ratio point more.
But what is glide ratio, anyway?
Glide ratio is a ratio
between vertical distance
— as shown here —
vertical distance and horizontal distance.
And on most modern wings this ratio
is between 8 and 10. High-performance wings sometimes a bit more,
but mostly somewhere between 8 and 9.
Take 9 as an example —
that means with 1 metre of altitude
we can fly 9 metres horizontally.
With 1000 metres of altitude,
from launch to landing,
we can theoretically fly 9 kilometres.
But that's a very theoretical value.
Always keep in mind
that you might have a bit of sink,
or maybe headwind, and then the ratio
between the speeds suddenly looks completely different.
And when I'm planning a flight,
I mostly don't calculate with 9 or 10 either —
instead, when I'm calculating distance,
say I want to clear that,
go over the forest,
then I take a glide ratio of 6 or 5,
(unclear)
so that I'm being really conservative
— conservative — and won't run into any problems.
One way to calculate glide ratio
is the distance covered on both axes.
Or you take the lift coefficient divided by the drag coefficient,
and you always end up with the same value — the glide ratio.
And here we see again,
back to the topic we just covered:
if the drag gets smaller,
and lift stays the same,
that means the glide ratio grows — gets bigger.
Or, for the theory exam:
glide angle is not the same as glide ratio.
A big glide ratio is a good thing —
we fly far —
but it means the glide angle is small.
And when the glide ratio is smaller,
like in this example of 5,
then the glide angle is bigger.
So the glide angle is always
the angle from the horizontal —
you could imagine the ground and our flight path.
And when the glide ratio is better,
i.e. bigger,
then the glide angle gets flatter and flatter.
Then we come to the polar curve.
It's very theoretical here,
we've already heard a bit about it in the flying practice.
Mostly you just need to know
what to do in which situation.
Because we're not always
in absolute zero-wind conditions,
where the whole air is just sitting still —
instead we have updrafts, downdrafts,
headwind, and sometimes we have tailwind.
And we can also overbrake the wing,
stall it, and over-accelerate it,
so we always get the maximum out of the wing
and can travel as far as possible,
or stay up as long as possible.
On the next few slides I'll try
to show you
what happens with these points on the graph
when we have wind influence.
Basically, in trim flight —
that is, with no brake input —
the paraglider is built exactly
to glide as well as possible.
That means we're at the best glide.
The red line here
is the entire speed range of the paraglider,
from the far left — the stall.
So if you brake any more there,
the airflow breaks away,
we're too slow,
we no longer have enough lift.
Angle of attack is too big, we're no longer flying.
From there you can release the brakes,
then we get faster,
and we arrive at the minimum sink point,
at the minimum sink,
where the ratio of the paraglider
isn't quite as good as at best glide.
But we're sinking the least.
In the end it always comes down to
the ratio being as good as possible —
not the one or the other speed.
So as I said,
trim speed gives you best glide,
and when you step on the accelerator
you push out to maximum speed.
To be able to favourite it,
we're then at almost the
fastest speed,
(unclear)
But the ratio is always best where
the tangent — the green line —
touches our state curve, i.e. our polar curve.
Now let's run this with headwind.
The green line starts at the zero point.
If we now have four metres of headwind,
we can start the line further along.
And then we see
from here to here
our point shifts
further towards maximum speed.
If we have even more wind, like seven, eight metres per second,
the tangent shifts further and further,
and the point of best glide
is at some point — when you're fully on the accelerator — at full speed.
Where exactly that point is, and at how much wind,
depends very much on the wing.
Every wing is a bit different,
it depends on the loading.
There are so many factors
that you can hardly calculate it —
you find it out.
In practice, the best thing is,
if you have a GPS device with glide-ratio calculation,
when you have headwind
you can use the accelerator
and just try it out.
Half accelerator,
full accelerator,
and only braking a little.
It's more like braking —
and now we come to tailwind.
You see, here we have zero wind,
here we have a tiny bit of tailwind,
here we have more tailwind,
and the original best-glide point —
the tangent shifts further upward,
towards minimum sink.
Minimum sink is about 15 to 20% braked,
slightly braked,
so that we sink less.
Because the tailwind,
if you count it positively,
so to speak...
Because the wind pushes us from behind,
and so we automatically have a good glide ratio.
And if you slightly — or simply with the tailwind —
swim with it, so to speak.
In updraft you see exactly the same thing:
if I, with the green line,
shift the original point again,
towards minimum sink.
And if you have a lot of updraft,
it can even be
that you can still
give even more brake input.
That's all very, very theoretical,
because if there's only two metres per second of thermal climb,
for example,
it doesn't really matter how well it glides.
Rather, you'd just fly it as is,
so that in straight flight you simply have two metres of climb.
Does that work?
But let's just say,
it happens rarely.
And if you have such strong climb
that the best-glide point
is way up there,
then you're probably circling anyway.
And not doing distance flight.
And when you're circling,
it's always a nice climb.
Then it's much more important —
as you heard earlier —
to use weight shift in the flying practice.
And centre the thermal as well as possible —
centring the thermal well
is much more efficient
than getting the exact right brake position
for best glide.
With downdraft,
in downdraft,
you can also say,
in a downdraft,
you actually want to get out as fast as possible.
Headwind is usually
something
that lasts a long time —
it's simply the wind,
the prevailing ground wind,
always a headwind
in that direction.
With downdraft,
in practice,
you usually only have it briefly,
in a downdraft,
and there you can basically
just say:
just accelerate,
to get out of the downdraft,
as quickly as possible,
and on top of that,
what's more,
at the same time
the glide gets massively better when accelerating.
That's actually the takeaway:
you accelerate in downdraft and headwind.
How much exactly,
that's very
wing-dependent.
In updrafts,
you slightly brake,
(unclear)
as in this case afterwards
Accelerator inputs in this afterward
if the situation allows it, if you've planned correctly,
you have enough space to make it to the landing.
So, the accelerator gets us further, because you accelerate.
Of course it's clear that risk increases and reactions are also more violent.
That's why with the accelerator,
(unclear)
It's that the accelerator...
...is what we use when we have headwind.
Of course it makes our flight path steeper.
So the glide angle becomes bigger, glide ratio worse.
When you have tailwind, it's the exact opposite.
Then our glide ratio gets bigger, and the glide angle gets flatter.
And the reason is simply that our sink rate always stays the same.
So as far as gliding goes, it doesn't matter to us
what air mass we're in —
(unclear)
Metres per second to km/h is essential.
It's a very common calculation,
because most paragliders have roughly
a trim speed of 36 or 5.30 km/h.
For the example: metres per second, we say the paraglider
with 6.10 m/s...
We have a paraglider
that flies 10 m per second.
Then that's metres per second.
Afterwards we hit a downdraft,
where the air additionally sinks one metre.
We move relative to the air,
we sink one metre,
but the whole air package also sinks one metre per second.
That means, in total, we have two metres,
so on a vario,
we'd be at minus two metres per second.
And that means
that our glide ratio drops massively,
so we're at — for that example — 5.00 km.
Because then we only fly 10 m per second,
but have two metres of sink,
the 10 m / 2 m gives a glide ratio of 5.
Then we have movement around three axes.
On a paraglider,
we have the lateral axis —
when the paraglider keeps pitching up
and is a bit jittery,
then we say
it's longitudinal instability,
because it pitches back and forth around the lateral axis.
Then we have the longitudinal axis,
that's rolling, or flying wingovers,
where a wingover is
a combination of many axes.
But we say
the movement around the longitudinal axis is rolling.
And there we get lateral
stability.
When a wing doesn't fly
very stably straight ahead,
that's lateral stability.
And then we have directional stability.
The vertical axis would actually go through the pilot,
right through and up through the wing.
Movement around it — when the wing kind of does this
in the air —
that's called yawing.
And then we have stability,
because when a paraglider is stable,
that means
that after a disturbance
it returns to the original state.
You can picture it
as a bowl.
And if you put
a wedge in it,
it always comes back
to the lowest point,
rolls back to it.
And when...
...the wing flies out again,
or you accelerate,
then release the accelerator,
the wing goes back to the original state.
That's a wing meant for the awards.
On a paraglider with progressive development you'll see, in practice — and these are the technical terms for it.
Indifferent is when a wing keeps flying in the direction it was pushed.
So, when a ball gets a push on a flat surface,
and it has no rolling resistance, it just keeps rolling, straight ahead.
So when a wing gets a gust from the left, and instead of swinging back and forth two or three times,
and then flying straight ahead again, it just goes into a turn and keeps the turn.
So that's the difference between labile, stable, and indifferent.
I hope that, maybe with these bowls and
balls, it's a little easier to remember. Then we get to turn flight.
In turn flight, a load factor arises.
So we see again: vertical is gravity, against it is lift — when you're flying straight,
we have 1 G, just our body weight. When we start turning,
the forces increase. You can calculate it with angle math, or you can draw it.
And when we draw it, we can measure,
and from those measurements we can determine that, when you pull a full turn,
the turn force, the FK, at 70° is exactly three times as long as our gravity vector.
And at 60° it would be 2G, so twice as long, and at 45° it would be 1.4G.
So 1.4 times our own body
weight. In turn flight — this is the wording on an exam question — in turn flight
the load factor increases, that is the load on the whole system.
And
the FK shifts massively. Every element of the polar curve simply gets faster.
Your trim speed gets faster, your maximum flight speed gets faster,
but also your stall speed — your airflow break-away speed — is higher.
In a turn you have to be careful because of stall.
Flying really fast in the turn is no guarantee
that you won't stall, because at higher wing loading we also need more speed
to keep the airflow from breaking away.
In practice it happens less often, because we also notice more pressure on the brake.
But equally important to know: all the speeds increase.
So both minimum speed and trim speed on the wing.
As soon as the forces increase.
Right, then I'd like to thank you for your attention.
And I hope I could help you again in this part.
And that you're now motivated for the theory.
Yes, study it really well.
Work through the questions, and then go to the theory exam successfully and pass.
And hopefully also in practice,
that one or two things make a bit more sense, or that you have a few more aha moments in this area.
We'll see you, see you soon.